un petit calcul pour le fuel voyez c'est
pour une cuve de fioul de 2000 euros
c'est 590 euros avec mes mesures par an
que peuvent gagner les français quant à
la prime moyenne parlons de la valeur
travail mais la grande différence entre
la proposition que j'ai pu faire
d'incitation des entreprises et votre
proposition de prime moi je veux que je
dis aux entreprises voilà si vous
augmentez de 10% les salaires jusqu'à 3
fois le smic eh bien je gèlerait les
cotisations patronales subséquentes et à
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales subséquentes c'est certes un
manque à gagner ça n'est pas une dépense
dirais que c'est un manque à gagner je
l'admets mais ses dépenses dans le
budget or monsieur macron mais les
primes dans la vraie vie oui quand vous
allez demander à amerrir votre banque on
est tous de vie marine le pen dans la
vraie vie quand vous allez chercher un
prêt auprès de votre banque et vous
demande votre salaire et il se moque des
primes quand dans la vraie vie vous
allez pour louer un appartement est bien
le propriétaire ils vous demandent
combien vous gagnez en salaire il se
moque des primes parce qu'il sait que un
coup vous l'aurez la prime et puis
peut-être un coup vous ne l'aurez pas
donc on voit bien que la mesure que je
propose d'augmentation des revenus est
quelque chose qui est capable
d'améliorer la vie quotidienne des
fourons mentez pas les villes
administrées vous n'administrer là les
salaires la mairie mais vous ne me ferez
pas et primes non plus passionnant mais
au moins on l'enlève j'incite et
j'enlève les charges et impôts mais ce
que ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
j'assume pour le coup cette mesure et je
rend obligatoire le mécanisme mais vous
n'augmentez pas de 10% les salaires donc
aussi vrai j'assume totalement que la
prime à une part d'aléas qui dépend de
l'année vous avez parfaitement raison
mais ce que vous dites est aussi
aléatoire je voudrais pas que nos
compatriotes qui qui pensent que ce sera
de manière sûre sur leurs feuilles de
paye un président en présidente de la
république et puissent décider de ce qui
est sur la sellette clairement qu'il
s'agit d'une incitation auprès des gens
dont il y aura bien une augmentation de
10% s'il y aurait une augmentation savez
vous allez aider comme oppose deux des
fils de défiscaliser la prime mais vous
n'allez pas le décider pour l'employeur
mais ça va changer leur vie quotidienne
allocs mais la venelle n'est pas décidé
pour l'employeur vous n'allez pas faire
les pas dans leur vie non mais vous le
faites vous les pas faire les salaires
madame le pen et vous ne ferez pas non
plus les primes 6 nov mais je veux dire
je le dis tu en voilà jeudi j'enlève les
charges du côté employeurs j'enlève les
impôts mais vous essayez de faire croire
que vous vous allez augmenter les
salaires de 10% que ce sera récurrent je
dis juste non c'est pas vrai
[Musique]